sometimes when you're Jennifer Lopez you  just gotta stop to smell the roses and  pose for a super sultry selfie I really  feel blessed the stunning 47 year old  posted this babe Alicia's photo to  Instagram Thursday rocking just a tiny  one-piece  JLo showed off some side boob and of  course her iconic derriere the triple  threat got candid in the caption  spreading her message of body positivity  and healthy living she shared the  hashtags love yourself first feeling  empowered healthy body healthy mind I  love dancing and definitely I don't love  the gym as much as I love to dancing so  it's a good thing for for my abs  ét sat down with JLo in 2015 where she  opened up about aging  I refuse to be put in a box in that way  do you know what I mean why because I'm  over 40 so it can't be sexy or is it  because I'm a mom this is a beautiful  thing that I can be standing here right  now at this time feel okay comfortable  healthy in shape at this age